bizarre oui c'est c'est certain que
quand on apprend ça quelques années plus
tard
on se pose des questions
donc écoutez le pitch de votre bouquin
est simple il est contenu dans le titre
du livre c'est mon père Francis le Belge
voilà comme ça au moins c'est simple et
définitif sécher Jean-Claude latesse
voilà le 27 septembre 2000 c'est en
allumant la télévision que vous apprenez
l'assassinat de votre père donc Francis
le Belge deux hommes casqués qui entrent
dans un PMU et lui réalise que son heure
est arrivé et il ouvre ses bras en croix
donc attendant les balles qui allaient
le quel est le tuer est-ce qu'il
s'attendait à ça vous vous pensez à
cette époque je pense que tout au long
de sa vie de toute façon il savait très
bien comme je dis souvent qu'il ne
m'aurait pas dans son lit et surtout à
la fin de sa vie un mois auparavant il
venait de perdre son ange gardien comme
je dis c'était sa maman donc il pensait
de plus en plus à la mort et puis bon je
pense que pour lui c'était c'était une
évidence
du dernier parrain votre père Francis le
Belge ensuite flashback quand votre mère
le rencontre alors on l'appelle Francis
le Belge parce que son nom était un peu
dans sable à l'école primaire déjà c'est
vraiment pas un surnom qui lui a été
donné dans le milieu c'est vraiment à
l'époque de l'école primaire et primaire
pardon dans les vieux quartiers de
Marseille on a son nom était un
prononçable alors on l'a surnommé le
Belge alors au départ il est déménageur
il joue au football donc tout va bien il
fréquente votre mère mais mais gentiment
enfin comme un comastage là voilà et à
17 ans il commence par partir quatre
mois au Baumettes première connerie
premier emprisonnement et puis à partir
de là il était sur la sur la mauvaise
voie comme on dit quoi après ça ça a
continué jusqu'à la fin voilà alors il
prend un meublé avec votre mère au Prado
à Marseille et il lui offre une alliance
en diamant en guise de mariage
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'elle ait
jamais eu de champagne
je dirais l'apogée de sa carrière entre
guillemets donc il était encore assez
gentil avec elle et
des illusions et souffrances pour votre
mère quoi ça a été vraiment le grand
moment de leur vie c'est cette bague en
diamant exactement oui et
malheureusement ça n'a pas duré
longtemps parce que à 20 ans l'huile ne
pense qu'à réussir dans le milieu il
néglige énormément sa vie de couple il a
des maîtresses il sort etc et quand
votre mère lui annonce qu'elle est
enceinte de vous il lui ordonne
d'avorter il y a le refuse oui elle
refuse pour la première fois elle
s'oppose à mon père alors que quelque
part elle est sous son emprise déjà et
puis elle en a elle en a déjà peur mais
malgré tout elle s'oppose à lui pour la
première fois et puis elle décide de
mener sa grossesse à bien à terme mais
la seule solution pour elle en fait
c'est de quitter mon père
mais quelque chose dans leur empêcher
par la police elle refuse de balancer
votre votre père elle est accusée de
complicité de proxénétisme évidemment
elle est envoyée en prison et elle est
libérée une semaine avant votre
naissance oui heureusement d'ailleurs
je sais pas là on a eu énormément de
chance parce que ce serait encore
inscrit sur mon extrait de naissance
d'être en prison c'est quand même encore
plus lourd à porter que d'être Phil de
Francis le Belge
il y a un truc que je crois c'est
pourquoi votre père ne vous reconnaît
pas quand vous naissez
pas parce qu'il savait bien qu'il était
le père de cet enfant
aucun doute n'a aucun mais il me
reconnaît pas au départ parce que
quelque part ma mère s'est opposée à lui
elle lui a elle lui a désobéi donc sa
première punition c'est de la laisser à
l'emprison même si elle est enceinte par
deux fois il va la punir par la prison
ce qui est assez cruel quand même
surtout qu'ils savent ils savaient ce
que ce qui était la prison il l'a su
pendant très longtemps par contre ce qui
s'est passé en fait c'est qu'il n'a pas
il ne m'a pas reconnu tout de suite
parce que j'étais une fille voilà il a
dit à ses proches si ça a été un garçon
je l'aurais reconnu tout de suite
oh pardon
bizarre oui c'est certain que quand on
apprend ça quelques années plus tard
on se pose des questions
alors là vous vous installez avec lui
dans une magnifique villa à Vitrolles
alors là c'est vraiment le parrain tu
vois salle de bain en marbre de Carat
robinet plaqué or enfin une espèce de
prison dorée pour pour votre mère et
pour vous vous êtes très malheureuse en
fait on est très malheureuse moi
personnellement je ne mens pas trop con
de ce qui se passe mais je vois sur tous
les réactions de maman mon père descend
tous les six mois il a une vie
secondaire sur Paris avec une autre
femme avec Maria Vincent notamment donc
c'est reconnu c'est sûr maman le sait il
reste deux jours tous les six mois donc
j'ai pas le temps de m'attacher vraiment
à lui et la seule chose que je me rends
compte c'est que maman pleure qu'elle a
peur voilà
alors beaucoup d'argent qui vient du
proxénétisme qui vient de la drogue
c'est l'époque de la de la French
Connection
la guerre à l'époque contre le clan
Zampa le fameux Gaï tanzanpa sont son
rival éternel et est-ce qu'à l'époque
vous savez ce que fait votre père pas du
tout
non compte de rien je suis très protégée
parce que justement on le voit très peu
souvent
à cette époque là c'était pas encore
assez médiatisé comme aujourd'hui donc
forcément non je ne me rends compte
absolument de rien non vous savez pas
quoi alors lui il supporte rien il
supporte pas vos vos jeux d'enfant le
bruit que vous faites c'est que quand il
est pas là ça va quand il est là c'est
encore pire un jour par exemple il exige
que vous vous agenouillez pour embrasser
ses pieds oui en fait il était avec des
amis venait d'arriver et puis bon il
commence un petit peu à parler et puis
dire ma mère me voilà écoute tu sais
maintenant je suis le parrain donc tu
dois en être fier puis un coup dire ses
amis mais tout le monde doit être à mes
genoux et puis notamment ma fille elle
vient bien m'embrasser les pieds puis ma
mère s'est opposée à lui elle a dit non
non ça il avait pété les plombs ou je
sais pas il était peut-être devenu un
peu mégalou je sais pas il sait ça je
saurais pas expliquer sur le Los Angeles
ni ses paroles parce que moi-même je
suis maman de deux petites filles et je
ça me viendrait même pas chez vous
j'imagine
de trois ans oui voilà mais pas du tout
ça viendrait même pas l'esprit c'est
pour ça je ne peux absolument pas
l'expliquer
il y a un truc plus grave quand même
c'est que il vous utilise comme bouclier
humain si vous devenez un petit peu son
assurance vie parce qu'il dit que
finalement quand il sort avec vous c'est
difficile de lui tirer dessus quoi oui
mais ça c'est vraiment dans des
conditions spéciales c'est à dire que
mon père n'avait confiance en personne
et un jour sa maman lui dit écoute je
suis allé voir une voyante et puis
celle-ci m'a dit que tu t'accompagne
notamment ma mère cherche à te faire
tuer mais à partir de ce moment là mais
c'était à tout le temps avec moi et puis
en y réfléchissant ma main n'étant pas
au courant c'est vrai que quand j'ai su
cette anecdote qui m'a beaucoup touchée
m'a beaucoup perturbé je l'ai su en fait
après la mort de mon père par une amie à
lui
qui m'a expliqué en fait maman a fait le
rapprochement elle me dit c'est vrai que
lorsque il sortait il te mettait devant
lui alors maman a pris ça comme un geste
vraiment d'amour en disant ben oui il
veut voir sa fille plus souvent quelque
part mais c'est certaine que s'il avait
été au courant elle aurait elle aurait
refusé
vous avez pour lui des sentiments très
mitigés c'est des sentiments d'amour
comme on a pour son père en même temps
de haine par rapport à ça comportement
ça a été vraiment un très long parcours
puisque il y a pas très longtemps que je
m'en suis sorti je suis encore en
thérapie mais j'ai passé vraiment une
période de
d'hydogénido la très mon père c'était la
période fan je découpais tout tout c'est
vraiment j'avais un regard extérieur
pour moi c'est un personnage de fiction
totalement et ensuite j'ai eu ma période
lorsqu'il est mort où j'ai vraiment su
parce que j'ai lu les bouquins comme
tout le monde pour apprendre à prendre
vraiment ce qu'il était donc à partir de
là je me suis mise à le juger et à le
haïr et quelque part ça m'a dérangé de
haïr mon parce qu'on ne peut pas on n'a
pas le droit de juger ses parents donc à
partir de là j'ai commencé ma thérapie
j'ai sombré j'ai fait ma dépression ma
tante d'assise de suicide et là je suis
arrivée à stade une année après à être
neutre c'est à dire à ne plus juger mon
père voilà et ça m'a permis d'écrire ce
livre alors à l'époque votre père a des
maîtresses c'est donc secret de
polichinelle évidemment et votre mère
rencontre à notre homme dont elle aura
une deuxième fille votre sœur et quand
Francis le Belge l'apprend il menace de
tuer tout le monde il faut dire il la
prend d'une manière assez spéciale il
est en prison il apprend que depuis deux
ans maman est avec à une double vie il
apprend que la deuxième fille qui
croyait être la sienne n'est pas la
sienne
et bon mais ce qui est je pense que
c'est assez vexant d'autant plus qu'il
avait décidé de nous reconnaître enfin
toutes les deux c'est que le l'amant de
votre mère enfin tous les cas le père de
votre demi-soeur pour pour fuir est
obligé de s'habiller en mais en fait il
a été obligé de se grimer en femme bon
ça a été vraiment très succès mais moi
ça me suffisait c'était pour moi en fait
non juste raser les avant-bras raser les
avant-bras émis le peignoir de sa maman
en fait ce qui me permettait de penser
puisqu'il avait nuque un peu longue et
je suis un peu long de penser que
c'était une femme et ça m'évitait de
dénoncer quelque part l'homme que voyait
ma mère en pensant que c'était tatie
Paulette
c'est énorme et alors votre mère pour
avoir la paix à un moment parce que
votre père menace non seulement votre
mère mais sans Jules enfin le père de
votre demi-sœur et à un moment votre
mère était obligé ça s'arrange pas
l'entourage des Gaston de fer etc et et
elle dépose une enveloppe chez un
notaire où elle balance toute la vérité
en disant s'il m'arrive quelque chose
bah ça sera voilà ce que mon père
apprend tout ça en prison on est obligé
de fuir alors Tati Paulette s'est mis en
congé sans solde maman est partie sans
rien on a tout laissé on nous a tout
pris et puis on est allé se cacher dans
un petit village
de quelques habitants à côté de Sisteron
voilà et c'était pour nous avec ma sœur
on l'a vécu ça très bien c'est les
vacances improvisées bon il y a qu'une
chose qui était un petit peu curieuse
c'est que on était hors-saison on était
dans un petit village de montagne c'est
à dire une station de sport d'hiver et
on était les seuls dans la pension de
famille voilà mais à un moment vous
allez voir votre votre père en prison
entre 8 et 16 ans vous le voyez
seulement à travers une vitre à votre
père qu'il a fallu les parloirs libres
pour que vous puissiez le le toucher les
tables aménagées les tables rondes avec
des chaises et puis toute la famille et
là ta famille paternelle on est tous là
au rendez-vous puis pour moi c'est
vraiment le choc parce que quelque part
sur Marseille maman se fait opérer pour
une opération très grave et j'avais pas
envie d'être là quoi j'avais envie
d'être avec maman
d'être avec elle et puis en même temps
j'ai envie aussi de découvrir ce père et
puis de le toucher enfin et quand je
touche malgré moi oui il se passe
quelque chose là c'est mon père euh
finalement il sort de prison et en 92 il
peut pas assister à votre à votre
mariage non et c'est pas qui ne peut pas
de toute façon mon père n'entre dans
aucune église n'est jamais entrer dans
une église et se refuse à le faire donc
de toute façon il n'aurait pas été là
bon on comprend aussi qu'il est interdit
séjour dans la région PACA donc pour lui
assister à mon mariage c'est impossible
en même temps quelque part ça m'arrange
parce que la place à côté de moi c'est
pas la sienne c'est la place de mon père
de mon beau-père qui est mon père de
coeur qui allait tellement
extraordinaire et puis qui m'a tellement
comblé cet amour qui m'a manqué je gère
très vite taipolette qui s'est
transformé mais oui c'est c'est marrant
mais je l'ai reconnu tout de suite quoi
je veux dire je n'ai de souvenir de bons
souvenirs caractipolette ou avec mon
père de coeur que j'appelle papa j'ai
pas honte de le dire
vous dites c'est pas tellement comme
comme dans les films de Coppola où on
voit des tas de cadeaux etc vous vous
avez un magnétoscope et un four à
micro-ondes
aussi donc j'étais ravie mais bon moi de
toute façon j'ai jamais eu la grande vie
donc moi ça m'a pas choqué mais en
faisant après ce livre j'ai quand même
fait une rapprochement et puis je veux
dire bah oui le parrain le frotte que
dans le Francis francopola c'est pas
pareil quoi
alors vous dites pour conclure meilleurs
voyous que pair quand même
parfait et je veux dire il a toujours
respecté il a toujours payé pour ce
qu'il a fait d'ailleurs il en est mort
mais bon c'était pas mon père alors bon
il a peut-être des
circonstances atténuantes c'est à dire
que il a souvent été en prison il n'a
pas grandi avec moi il était pas préparé
à cette paternité il l'a voulait pas
donc à partir de là c'est vrai que on
peut se poser tas de questions
mais c'est pas facile c'est vrai
ça commence ça commence mais je
c'est difficile de sortir tout ça parce
que pendant 34 ans je me suis tue
c'était un lourd secret en même temps
mon père m'a jamais donné le droit à la
parole jamais donner le droit de dire
qui j'étais jamais
depuis 33 ans
cet homme papa admirable tout ce que
j'ai je lui dois
les poils ont repoussé il a des cheveux
un peu plus blancs maintenant c'est un
papier extraordinaire et c'est
il y a pas de mots
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu